hello
hello everybody
good afternoon glad we didn't have to
say
good night like tonight meaning
and manu put in his put on his best
genes
for this event thank you
sorry his what cicada oh yeah i heard
about that cicada
did you bring him home in a little jar
or her are cicadas
male and female i don't even know who
knows
let's check the knowledgeable press
corps who knows if
cicada there are male and female there
you go
there you go okay good afternoon to all
my
friends in the press and my fellow
cicadas
no okay um before i lay out the agenda
for the upcoming june work period
i just want to say a few words about the
vote the senate just had on the
commission i won't say that much because
you heard me on the floor i'm sure
but you know this is democracy at stake
the bottom line is very simple if
americans lose faith in the veracity
and honor of our elections it's the
beginning of end of our democracy that's
what happens in dictatorships people
don't believe the elections
and donald trump has perpetrated the big
lie and this goes way beyond
party and i'm just terribly disappointed
that so many republicans refuse to even
look at a bipartisan down the middle
look at it
because they're afraid of donald trump
donald trump is a
is a is a bane to our democracy
and unless people in his own party stand
up to him
it's bad for the party it's bad for
those individuals
but most of all it's bad for the country
so i hope that will change
um okay now just reviewing
our last work period uh we've had a
really productive may session
our committees have advanced critical
issues in the president's buildback
better agenda
we confirmed many of the president's
nominees and we came together on a
bipartisan basis to advance
a historic and wide-reaching piece of
legislation the u.s innovation and
competition act the most significant
investment in science technology and
american manufacturing in an
entire generation this is one of the
most significant pieces of legislation
that's come before the senate in a very
long time
and it's going to have huge effects down
the road it doesn't get the attention it
should i've
said for three reasons number one
because it's bipartisan so there's no
fighting
you know i know you guys like fighting
number two
um because it is going to take effect
not immediately although the chips part
will but
in general it won't take effect but
it'll have dramatic effects
four five ten years from now and i
forgot the third reason
i had three reasons i said him in my
speech do you remember
what is it what
oh yeah it's positive not negative
okay it's a positive piece of
legislation okay
anyway we're very proud of it all right
um uh exercising our
authority over the cra the congressional
review act
we reversed several egregious trump era
rules that hurt our environment
and gave big corporations more power
over american workers
circumvented critical protections for
consumers
we also we witnessed president biden
sign
the covet 19 hate crimes act it's a
piece of legislation that originated in
the senate
and it's critical to combating the wave
of attacks against asian americans
so those were all good things done on a
bipartisan basis
at the same time we have seen the limits
of bipartisanship
and the resurgence of republican
obstructionism
despite three months of regular orders
on yusika
the input of no fewer than six
committees dozens of republican
amendments
accepted to the bill 21 roll call and
voice votes on amendments
a vote out of the two major committees
21 to 1 and 24 to 4.
senate republicans sought to delay the
inevitable passage of you seeker by two
weeks
even as many american manufacturers are
experiencing devastating semiconductor
shortages and pleading with us
for help it was only when this morning
when the five or six republicans who
were holding up the bill saw all 50
democrats on the floor that they
realized they couldn't roll
us and then they accepted our agreement
but it ensures that euseka will pass
as soon as we resume legislative session
maybe even worse certainly worse senate
republicans at the personal request of
leader mcconnell
can continue their brazen attempts to
whitewash the attack of january 6th
by filibustering the house passed
bipartisan january 6 commission even
though
as i said speaker pelosi and i agreed to
change as proposed by senator collins
she still they were still only able to
get six votes
senators should rest assured that the
events of january 6 will be investigated
and that as majority leader i reserve
the right to force the senate to vote on
the bill
again at the appropriate time senate
democrats are doing everything we can
to move bipartisan legislation when we
can where the opportunity exists
and but we will not wait for months and
months to pass meaningful legislation
that delivers real results for the
american people so looking ahead
when the senate reconvenes on june 7th
we'll force a vote on hr 7.
that's called the paycheck fairness act
it's equal pay for women
it's a long overdue piece of legislation
it's supported by all 50 democrats
it previously was filibustered by senate
republicans during president obama's
second term
it's common sense of legislation and i
have promised
it will receive a vote in the senate and
in a couple of weeks it will
we'll also begin to confirm president
biden's judicial nominees
including very famous and illustrious
judge katanji brown jackson for the very
important court of appeals of the dc
circuit the senate may also
i i may also ask the senate to consider
gun legislation and lbgtq equality
legislation
during the june work period and finally
in the last week of the june work period
the week of june 21st
the senate will vote on s-1 before the
people act
legislation vital vital to
defending our democracy reducing the
influence of dark money that pernicious
influence
of powerful special interests and
stopping the wave of republican voter
suppression
happening in states across the country
in service to the president
president trump's big lie so i repeat
the senate will vote on
s-1 before the people act the week of
june 21st
in addition the senate democratic
majority will continue to make progress
on president biden's build back
better economic agenda we had two things
going at once which shows you will work
bipartisan where we can
and senator carper and senator kapital
reported unanimously out of epw
the ground transportation the road
transportation bill
but at the same time the senate finance
committee
reported historic clean energy
legislation that will begin to fight
climate change
and that passed fort camp was voted in
committee 14 to 14. that was not
obviously bipartisan so as the president
continues to discuss
infrastructure legislation with senate
republicans
our committees are going to hold
hearings and continue their work
on build back better with or without the
report
the support of republican senators
we must pass comprehensive jobs in
infrastructure legislation this summer
the american people gave us a democratic
senate to produce big and bold change on
the major issues confronting us and that
is what we are doing
ready for your questions we'll start
here and work on you change your usually
you're over here
um peter schumer how much more time
should you give
bipartisan negotiations on
infrastructure you sound in your letter
to your colleagues a little frustrated
with working with republicans well we're
first we were frustrated
when we did the most bipartisan bill i
think you'll check it
there were more amendments on this bill
than in several years of mcconnell's
entire
tenure as majority leader you know
certain years so it is frustrating that
when you go totally bipartisan we take a
lot of tough votes
on republican amendments that they still
not just that they still
try to block it a group of them but
mcconnell's nowhere on the floor nowhere
around trying to prevent that from
happening
and so um it is frustrating but that's
not going to stop us where we can from
working in a bipartisan way
that's the preferred way to go it's just
not possible in many different areas
with this republican senate and won't
stop us from acting
yes how long should it happen
look i have faith if the president and
my beliefs are the same we'll try to go
bipartisan when we can
but it shouldn't stop us from the kind
of big bold action we need
and i have faith in the president and uh
we talk all the time
and he's going to try to pursue
bipartisan where he can but not let it
stop him
yes no no no no manu you're
you could wear those jeans and have a
cicada but gotta wait your friends
uh thank you senator trevor what are
your views on uh congress
i guess democrats in congress moving
forward with a select committee
to investigate january 6. well look it
should be investigated it would be much
better to do it in a bipartisan way and
that's what
uh this bill did um but uh
better to investigate with with a select
committee than not investigate
um you had exchange with senator collins
on the senate floor just ahead of the
january 6 commission vote i just want to
see if you could talk
to us a little bit i'll just be brief
about it um senator collins
um wanted to make sure that senator
portman knew
that i supported her amendments which i
told many senators including mansion
and uh so i told her i would and i went
and told him and he voted yes
yes senator schumer um
senator mcconnell says the exact
opposite of you he says that
surprise surprise suppose
for democrats to do these big bold
things just yesterday he said the
president's team and ought to sort of
sober up on these big plans
what makes you think as you bring well
let's take let's take the boldest thing
we've done the arp
supported by 75 percent of the american
people
and 60 percent of republicans there's a
huge dichotomy
as president biden has repeatedly
pointed out between republican voters
and republican senators and congressmen
60 percent of republicans support arp
zero republicans in the house and senate
vote for it it's because unfortunately
they're under the thumb of donald trump
who wants nothing
done but that's not where republicans
really are
yes senator you're scheduling a vote on
s1 without the support of joe manchin is
your bet that he comes around
by the end we've had two very good
strong and intense discussions in our
caucus
as recently as wednesday and we're
continuing to have them at those caucus
lunches
it was made clear how important s1
is to the country to our democratic
majority and to individual senators and
those discussions are ongoing and
uh i have a lot of faith in them yes
thank you senator uh where are you then
as you're
saying that you know you're open to
working with republicans and
infrastructure where are you in the
reconciliation process if that doesn't
come together
look as i've said we try to work with
republicans where we can but we need big
bold action
and uh reconciliation is certainly a
serious consideration to get that big
bold action if we can't get it with
republicans
the filibuster of the january 6 bill
today and any of the actions that
surrounded this china competitiveness
bill
make you feel any more willing to or
open
to the idea of filibuster reform i know
this is going to be a big call
considering look i think
the events of the last few days probably
made every member of our caucus realize
that a lot of our republican colleagues
are not willing to work with us on a
whole lot of issues even issues where we
try to be bipartisan
nope it was somebody was i'm trying to
get everybody here
um you mentioned that you talked pretty
frequently to president
biden do you sense any impatience on his
part or on the
uh his staff's part with republican
intelligence he said he's a very patient
fellow but he's a persistent fellow and
as i said he'll keep talking to
republicans when he thinks there's an
opportunity to get something done but
he's not going to let it get in the way
of getting the kind of big bold action
he and i believe america needs
and requires and wants yes would you
change the deadline for the january 6th
commission if you're going to have votes
on
later later i'm not going to it's right
now leader mcconnell we all know twisted
a lot of arms
not to get it not to even move to
proceed if we were to get a vote to move
proceed we could begin to discuss
different aspects so manu yeah thank you
you said that you're open to a select
committee in the house would you
encourage your chairman in the senate to
investigate this
number one and number two two members of
your caucus skip today's vote
is that okay with you given how
important of a vote this was okay
i'm not going to get into individual
members of our caucus we always made
sure we'd have enough votes
on all of the issues um on the first
issue
i have a lot of faith already senator
klobuchar and senator peters are looking
extensively at what went on on january 6
and i have a lot of faith in what
they're doing and a lot of it they're
working together
and occasionally they reach out to other
committees like intelligence that
where they need some expertise there too
yes
you got two that's more than one house
does end up moving towards the select
committee democrats end up pushing this
forward how quickly do you think they
should
move on that and are you worried that
any findings would lose credibility with
the american public if it's not
available
i prefer to be preferred to do it
bipartisan we
every democrat voted for bipartisan but
the facts must come out
how quickly though go ahead next senator
schumer yesterday
republican senators stood where you're
standing now and proposed using
leftover coveted money money that's been
appropriated for years now to
pay for infrastructure is that a red
line for you or would you consider doing
that look we need big bold
i'm not going to get into the specifics
we need big bold action
and that means we need very significant
infrastructure money along the lines of
what president
biden has proposed go ahead president
hey uh
you do you just went like this i hardly
saw his hand well if you don't have a
budget resolution
on your your colleagues with you uh are
you bringing it you're
gonna bring the floor i said i think i
said previously that uh we would look to
do that in july
this is about june next uh
the the craigo wyden amendment got 91
votes yesterday at blah blah partisan
support
why didn't you want that in the
substitute amendment and did
chairman wyden fully apprise you of the
deal yes president
president chairman wyden
sometimes has the power of a president
over certain matters
um we were in touch all the time
there were some objections uh to that
provision
from the administration yes thank you
you said on the floor last hour you hope
that this wasn't
indicative of republican instruction on
other bills but why would we not think
what we saw the past couple of days
that vote on the one six million why
would you not think this is the
beginning of the end
philip looked about i've said it over
and over again
we have to have big bold action we have
to uh
we cannot fail on key things to our
democracy like s1 and everything's on
the table
and we're going to continue to discuss
it as we move forward it sounds like
you're thinking
that's all i'm going to everything's on
the table we hope we can get bipartisan
support
uh so far we have not seen any glimmers
on s1
um and if we don't everything's going to
be on the table
mr leader last one the patient
you de bonus counselor brooker has to
have a deal on policing next month will
you guarantee that you will bring that
to the floor and next month is
lgbt pride month you mention the lgbt
equality builder you are guaranteeing a
vote on it why not
well it's one of the things we're
considering on lgbtq we believe in it
strongly you know it's a very busy june
and uh so it's we're we're looking at it
what was the first thing
uh will you guarantee a vote on a
policing deal look
senator booker briefed me yesterday
they're making good progress i'm not
going to set any artificial deadlines
but i would hope that they could come to
a good bipartisan agreement
thank you everybody nope have a nice
break and i will not use the words for
the bonus for you
patient thank you everybody the cicadas
love them now
they are very patient right 17 years
worth
2038 midterms did uh
thank you